foreign
my beliefs and stance and also what I'm
willing to say has completely changed in
the last 24 months
this last week Stanford magazine which
is a magazine of the Stanford Alumni
Association goes out to many more people
than just two attended Stanford
put out an issue of this it's a very
nice bound magazine of the kind that you
would you know take the dentist officer
you know
on the cover and inside there's a
feature article about psychedelics I
could not believe it at first but it is
essentially a guide to psychedelics it's
not telling you how to do them but it
explains what is ketamine now here
they're broadly defining psychedelics
okay so the classic psychedelics right
psilocybin musculine LLC are included
there chemical structures how they're
used the history clinical trials
happening now known benefits
considerations and risks
for all of those drugs plus ketamine
plus MDMA I was just shocked a
positively shocked because three years
ago five years ago certainly ten years
ago a conversation like this would have
been the conversation that would have
ended my career yes as a university
professor
my understanding is that thanks to the
incredible work of the group with maps
and a number of specific Laboratories
Matthew Johnson's laboratory Robin
carder Harris's laboratory role in
Griffith's laboratory and thanks to the
philanthropy organized by you and others
truly and also thanks to the public
education efforts of people like Michael
pollen for sure we are moving very
quickly towards legalization of MDMA as
administered by
either psychiatrist and or licensed
clinical psychologist in the U.S
psilocybin probably a longer road but
I'm told that we'll get there quote
unquote
why am I framing it this way well I'll
just be very direct in high school I
took LSD recreationally several times
had not good experiences the experiences
were far too long 11 15 hours I might
have spent my senior prom in an elevator
you know it may or may not you know my
junior prom my senior prom was a
different story and I'm not recommending
people do this I actually strongly
regret doing that at a time when my
brain was plastic I did not know what I
was doing I didn't know the sourcing
it was a terrible idea terrible idea
even riskier now yeah and keep in mind
folks I was not a star student far from
it it took a lot of years to get my my
act together talked about this before in
Tim's podcast Richard Schultz podcast
another so you know that certainly did
not help and I don't recommend it I
tried psilocybin recreationally a few
times
didn't get much out of it as an adult
I'm not shy about the fact that I did
two and now three of the
Maps appropriate
physician guided sessions for trauma
using MDMA I've found it immensely
beneficial I'm happy to talk about how
each one of those sessions was different
again this is with a physician as part
of a
study so
what I know now is completely different
than what I knew two years ago which is
not just based on the legality but in
discussions with Nolan Williams this
incredibly impressive colleague of mine
and friend of yours and colleague of
yours really
that the safety profiles on things like
MDMA are actually quite High
I was taught that MDMA was neurotoxic
why was I taught that well there's paper
publishing Science magazine
looking at toxicity of MDMA
observing neurotoxic effects turns out
what were they looking at
methamphetamine oops retraction
retraction except that never made the
major headlines okay so then you look at
the data on psilocyb and here I'm just
going to hit the high points because
it's not my work it's the work of
Matthew Johnson and of Robin carnart
Harris at UCSF
intractable depression people who are
suicidally depressed nothing else Works
talk therapy doesn't work
antidepressants don't work TMS doesn't
work
do too high dose so it's 25 milligrams
of psilocybin that has to be translated
for grams of mushrooms but it's roughly
like the 25 to 30 milligram of
psilocybin synthetic psilocybin be
equivalent let's just say a Terence
McKenna heroic dose of five grams I mean
you're you're getting enough for escape
velocity okay yeah in upwards of 60
maybe 70 percent of these patients that
take that are getting substantial and
ongoing relief that's an amazing result
so much so that the big Pharma has moved
in and is trying to create
non-psychedelic psychedelics to extract
the benefits of these drugs that don't
induce hallucinations instead of raising
interesting questions about whether or
not the experience under psychedelics is
really the trigger for the
antidepressant effect whether or not
it's the inside or not that's a whole
ball of wax and really I'm not qualified
to parse that that's really the domain
of Robin and
and the Psychonauts that's an
interesting set of issues so my stance
nowadays is
there is a compound out there that seems
to have very high safety profiles very
very high certainly for psilocybin that
under the appropriate guidance and
supervision during and after in the
so-called integration phase one or two
dosages of this stuff yes takes people
through a phase of anxiety than a phase
of deep introspection this is also I
learned essential there are two
components I learned are essential that
were surprising to me one you have to be
in the eye mask observing things in your
external environment the whole time
seems to bypass some of the
introspective slash antidepressant
effects later that's interesting to me
it's not just about what you see what
you hear out there it's really about
going inward this kind of trust let go
yeah it's also important to standardize
for trials right you can't have people
looking at all sorts of different stuff
somebody's watching Finding Nemo and
another one's watching Jaws or right
exactly and then the other thing was I
learned from Robin recently is that
music seems to be a key component
now they've never teased out music no
music but having music that starts as he
described it in the distance you know
drums and pacing or something
approaching music
then instrumentals which raise people's
emotional state while they're in the eye
mask and then some transition period out
seems to be a critical component of all
this and guiding some of the kind of
funneling towards deep emotional
introspection
I find this incredibly interesting and
again I would have not felt safe talking
about this keep in mind a year ago two
years ago keep in mind that
in the late 60s early 70s there were
professors at Harvard and Stanford
mainly that were fired or at least asked
to leave for having discussions like
this yeah and now Stanford magazine
itself is printing this and this is also
I'll use this as an opportunity to say
this because it's really about the
listeners you know our podcast
Uber Lab podcast is free on all the
channels but we do have a premium
channel I'm not trying to solicit it
here but the premium channel is designed
to we do amas and things that sort
transcripts are available to those folks
to raise revenue for research dollars
for exciting work and we have a donor
that's very been very generous to do a
match for that money and we're giving
money only to studies working on humans
not animal studies and two of the major
errors that we're supporting are the
sorts of work that Nolan's lab is doing
and Nolan in particular
to combine transcranial magnetic
stimulation with psychedelics that's
great I didn't know that about about the
premium option yeah that's really what
the premium channel is designed for yeah
that's great again I'm going to say the
same people are going to think that I'm
just here you know kissing up to Tim but
I'm doing that over text all the time
anyway because this is yet another
example where you got into science
philanthropy early
you reach out to your connects you are
very vocal about what you felt was
powerful and it worked for you and what
you've been observing and I am
absolutely clear I've said this on
Twitter I'll say it again when we look
back in five years 10 years 100 years
there's going to be a small subset of
individuals For Whom the transition of
psychedelics from these like Niche
communities hippie communities carpet
Flyers everything from Devil's weed you
know craziness to True truly effective
compounds for treating psychiatric
illness
you're going to be on that list Roland's
gonna be on that list Matthew is going
to be on that list pollen's going to be
on that list Robin's going to be on that
land for sure also you know and Nolan I
think is going to be on that list
there's gonna be a small subset of
people that we're going to go listen
research takes money it takes focus it
takes a bravery and it also takes the
willingness to like take something that
has been looked at as just like drugs
you know and turn it into something
that's therapeutically meaningful so
yeah we're just all I'm trying to do is
you know raise some dollars through the
premium channel that's what we've been
doing to pump into research studies and
so what I mean you can tell I'm super
excited by all this what I see happening
now is that soon MDMA
for trauma is going to be available to
the countless numbers of people out
there that have trauma and I don't mean
just take MDMA and have a great time I'm
I mean people developing empathy for
themselves I mean people really working
through the barbed wire stuff of their
past much of which they had no control
over that sets this transgenerational
thing that's been going on for so long I
mean really you know you've used the
language you know been the Arca history
like these compounds are going to bend
the Arca history in the right direction
and if people out there are listening
and saying okay well this is like
recreational stuff and it's very
precarious I do not know a single major
let's just call them what they are CEO
or company founder we're talking about
people that kind of billionaire level
that are hyper creative hyper creative
and Hyper functional in their life we're
not talking about Mystic creatives we're
talking about people who I don't want
named names but every single one of them
already knows this is true because
they've all done this stuff already and
I was kind of late to the train because
I had such a terrible experience in my
high school years and saw so many
friends dead suicide drug addicts in
jail like wrecked their lives I had so
many challenges taking myself from
essentially a loser with nowhere to go
to you know a trajectory within Academia
and taking good care of my body that I
was like no drugs no drugs I don't even
put psyched dogs in the category of
drugs and here I'm lumping MDMA and
they're provided it's done with a
licensed physician or clinician who can
guide this stuff it's been immensely
beneficial for me